ريوكي ياماغاتا
لديه مجموعة من العجلات ليس بالمعنى الحرفي للكلمة بالطبع
ولكن هذا الرجل يمكن أن يتحرك
كطفل كان yamagata دائمًا
يختار بسرعة التسابق ضد الآلات ذات
العجلات الفعلية
هو الدافع
لجسمك يتحرك بشكل أسرع عندما
تشعر أنك مطارد
لذلك أنا  تدرب من خلال التظاهر بالهروب
من السيارات ،
إنها عقلية لا يزال يحملها اليوم
هي التي دفعته للتأهل
لأولمبيادته الثالثة
حيث سيجري في
سباق 100 متر في سباق التتابع 100 متر رجال ،
وسيتم تعيينه كابتن الفريق الأولمبي الياباني
والمطالبة باللقب.  من أسرع رجل في اليابان ،
لقد كان هذا طريقًا طويلاً حتى حصلت على
أفضل ما لدي
، وركضت أقل من 10 ثوانٍ على طريق طويل
مليء
بالإصابات وقليل من الحظ في عام 2019 ، لقد
عانيت من انهيار في الرئة وألم في الساق
العام الماضي
، كان هذا حقك  لم تتأخر ركبتي في الألعاب الأولمبية
لمدة عام ، فمن المحتمل
أنك لم تكن مؤهلة ،
وأردت أن أصدق أنني سأصل
إلى الأولمبياد لكن جسدي لم يكن قادرًا على
مواكبة ذهني ،
أعتقد ذلك ب  بعد ذلك ، إذا
تم عقد الألعاب الأولمبية في ذلك العام ،
فربما لم أكن قد تأهلت ولكن
تم تأجيل طوكيو 2020 واستغل
ياماغاتا أقصى استفادة منه ،
حيث تعافى من الإصابة وأجرى تغييرات على
روتينه التدريبي
وهو الآن يبلغ ذروته في
الوقت المناسب
تمامًا.  يظل yamagata مركزًا ، حيث يقول إن
الجدل الدائر حول هذه الألعاب
التي تغذيها مخاوف الصحة والسلامة كان
صعبًا للتعامل مع
المصادر ،
وهذا وقت صعب وهناك
جزء مني يشعر بالضغط
ولكن آمل أن نبذل قصارى جهدنا في هذه
الألعاب الأولمبية.  طريقة لمساعدة العالم على أن
يصبح أكثر إشراقًا قليلاً ،
أعتقد أن هناك قيمة في الرياضة وأنا
أحاول أن أجد معنى في الجري
والالتزام بهذا المعنى الجديد
وربما منظور جديد
بعد سنوات من عدم اليقين ، لقد كان
طريقًا صعبًا حقًا للوصول إليه  أولمبياد طوكيو
وتغلبت على الكثير من التحديات ولكني
أريد أن أحقق
أهدافي وأعطيها أفضل ما لدي.هذا الهدف هو
الفوز بالميدالية
الذهبية وتمثيل اليابان بكل فخر هنا.
في المنزل
بليك essig CNN طوكيو